just south of downtown Los Angeles a new
building reaches up towards the sky when
finished it will include 306
condominiums six retail stores a rooftop
Sports Club five townhomes and a
swimming pool
it's called Evo
five months into a two-year construction
schedule Evo is 20 feet off the ground
the third floor will house 25 condo
units each with its own kitchen bathroom
and laundry a crew from the jobs
plumbing subcontractor Murray company
has begun laying out the deck 69 70 71
could be on Kaline they are led by Tim
McCarty a 30-year third-generation
plumber
trait a long time to get water to and
from the 25 units on this floor 336
pipes will need to pass through the
concrete deck to make room for those
pipes tim's crew lays down cans steel
cylinders open it both ends that will
create holes once the concrete is poured
each can has a number 35
these are all the destinations for all
our cans
gas pipe so what we do is go off with
this blueprint find our marks and then
this sheet here gives us all of our
sizing of our cans their challenge is
that all these cans have to be precisely
placed to fit inside walls that won't be
built for another five months there
really is no messing up when it comes to
deck layout if you do have them you know
and that's out of a wall it's a lot more
costly to have to go back and put that
can we're supposed to be left 25 left
and shooting
that's a good point moving a hole after
the concrete is poured can cost
thousands of dollars to make sure that
cans end up in the right place they rely
on the survey team Tim Harris and Monte
moose it's their job to match up Evo's
architectural plans with reality and
they just go by what we say and if they
build a wall then all the concrete and
all the work in and it's not in the
right place you know and it's our fault
it costs a lot of money the plumbing
crew have been given only two days to
set over a hundred cans and 250 blue
bangers
these what they call blue bears
and they stripped when they stripped the
form in this form this is what's gonna
be flushing to concrete the blue bangers
are used for screwing pipe hangers to
the underside of a deck
my philosophy is I'll get it when it's
done it's done you know but I'm gonna
frighten myself I'm making sure it's
right then having them hurry me and then
come back and say look and look at all
these cans on deck - that you know are
where they're supposed to be how come
now what am I supposed to go back and
say what you guys rushman you know
that's not professionalism